[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
heute ist mal wieder Zeit für ein
bisschen Geschichte für einen Tag der
wirklich sehr schrecklich war den später
aber viele doch wieder vergessen haben
mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir und ich
freue mich dass ihr wieder mit dabei
seid und ich bin Toni hallo zusammen ihr
hört diese Folge wie immer for free auf
der podcast-plattform eures Vertrauens
umso mehr freuen wir uns wenn ihr uns
dort folgt Bewertungen hinterlasst die
Glocke aktiviert oder uns auch Feedback
schreibt schreibt uns dafür eine Mail an
podcast@bild.de oder hinterlasst uns
eine Nachricht auf Instagram und jetzt
zur Geschichte
ich habe bei der Vorbereitung für diese
Episode wieder sehr viel gelernt und das
beginnt schon bei der Einordnung wir
berichten nämlich von einem der
schlimmsten Terroranschläge in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik und ich
wusste nicht mal wirklich dass es ihn
gab also ich meine ich habe das schon
mitbekommen aber
diese Einordnung die hat mir komplett
gefehlt und so wirklich viel wusste ich
davor auch nicht drüber es hat in
Deutschland natürlich einige
schreckliche Terroranschläge gegeben mir
fällt da sofort aus der jüngeren
Vergangenheit der Anschlag vom
Breitscheidplatz auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt
in Berlin ein und natürlich auch die
Brandanschläge auf Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund in den 90ern in
Mölln und Solingen und natürlich auch
das Attentat zur Olympiade 1972 in
München ja Mirko ich bin da voll bei dir
ich hätte vielleicht auch noch an den
Terror der RAF gedacht an die 70er Jahre
so aber ja aber wir gehen heute zum 26
September 1980 und zwar nach München
einen Tag später meldet die Tagesschau
was passiert ist
guten Abend auch knapp 22 Stunden nach
dem Bombenanschlag auf das Münchner
Oktoberfest
herrscht über Täter und Motive noch
immer Unklarheit in der Ermittlungen
haben sich inzwischen
Sprengstoffexperten des
Bundeskriminalamtes sowie general
Bundesanwalt triebmann eingeschaltet ein
Sprecher redet man sollte keine Gründe
für die Übernahme der Ermittlungen
bekannt geben die Zeit zum gegenwärtigen
Zeitpunkt nicht zu verantworten
möglicherweise werde seine Behörde aber
morgen eine Stellungnahme abgeben
der Ansicht von Beobachtern spricht dies
dafür dass die Behörden über
Anhaltspunkte verfügen dass die Täter in
terroristischen Kreisen zu suchen sind
weder bestätigen noch dementieren
wollten die Ermittlungsbehörden bis zum
Abend das am Tatort der Ausweis eines
Mitglieds der als rechtsradikal
eingestuften biersportgruppe Hoffmann
gefunden worden sein der schwerste
Bombenanschlag in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik hat bis zur Stunde 12
Menschen leben und 140 Verletzte
gefordert unter den Opfern ist
möglicherweise auch ein Attentäter und
was die Tagesschau nicht so deutlich
schildert da steht zwei Tage später in
der Bild am Sonntag
12 tote
144 verletzte das Blutbad von München es
war wie im Krieg grauenvolle
unterleibsverletzungen abgetrennte
Gliedmaßen quellende Gehirne
aufgerissene Bäuche wie operierten bis
morgens um sieben
so beschreiben Ärzte des Klinikums
rechts der Isar des Geschehen nach dem
Anschlag weitere Augenzeugen Berichte
und Schilderungen sind zumeist grelle
Erinnerungsfetzen Momentaufnahmen des
Horrors und der Verzweiflung von
Stichflammen einer ungeheuren Detonation
Funkenregen umher fliegenden
menschlichen Gliedmaßen wenn man den
Schreien Blut Fontänen und Chaos ist da
die Rede und in der Wand steht weiter
Heidi Kunzelmann 34 war mit ihrer
Freundin und deren Tochter Beate 11
Jahre auf der Wiesen ein lustiger Abend
mit karussellfahrten Zuckerwatte und
Festzelt besucht kurz nach 22 Uhr
wollten wir nach Hause
Beate musste schließlich ins Bett
flüstert Heidi Kunzelmann die
mittelschweren Verletzungen im
Schwabinger Krankenhaus liegt
plötzlich war der ein grelles Licht und
ein furchtbarer Knall mein Bein tat weh
und meine Bluse war zerfetzt und dann
sah ich Beate
ohne Kopf
solche Bilder zeigt die Tagesschau
natürlich nicht verständlicherweise aber
auch dort wird der Schrecken deutlich
weiße Tücher bedeckten die Toten
darunter auch drei Kinder sowie ein
Schweizer und ein britischer
Staatsbürger
zum Zeitpunkt der Detonation gegen 22
Uhr waren schätzungsweise 200.000
Menschen auf dem Gelände eine große
Menge strömte bereits nach Hause
ungefähr 1000 Besucher hielten sich in
unmittelbarer Nähe der Bombe am
Hauptausgang auf die Explosion erfasste
die Menschen in einem Umkreis von 50
Metern einige Opfer wurden durch die
Luft geschleudert und zerrissen man
braucht wirklich keine weiteren
Schilderung um zu begreifen ja das ist
der schlimmste Terroranschlag in
Deutschland den es bis dahin gegeben hat
und ist es bis heute wenn man nicht nur
die Toten sondern auch die Verletzten
zählt Moko bitte gib uns noch mal ein
Überblick durch die Explosion einer
handgefertigten Bombe werden 13 Personen
getötet und 221 verletzt 68 davon schwer
unter den Toten ist auch der Attentäter
die Menschen die gerade zufällig vor Ort
waren das wollen wir hier auch noch mal
betonen die sind nicht einfach eine Zahl
sie sind Töchter und Söhne Mütter Väter
und Geschwister die Toten sind Gabriele
Deutsch Robert gemeinwieser Axel Hirsch
Markus Hölzl Paul Lux
Ignaz Platzer
Ilona Platzer Franz Schiele Angela
schüttrichkeit Errol there Hodge Ernst
Vestner Beate Werner
ein weiterer Toter erweist sich schon
bald als der Täter Gundolf Wilfried
Köhler
geologiestudent geboren am 27 August
1959 in Schwenningen am Neckar
zum Zeitpunkt seines Todes ist der 21
Jahre alt Köhler hat gerade Abi und
Wehrdienst hinter sich als er sich auf
dem Oktoberfest in die Luft springt
Gundolf Köhler war der jüngste Sohn von
Werner und Marta Köhler die Familie
stammte eigentlich aus Sachsen aber die
Eltern zogen 1952 in den Westen
gundolfs Vater ist CDU-Anhänger die
Brüder Wellen SPD oder FDP Gundolf
Köhler aber begeistert sich schon früh
für den Nationalsozialismus er sammelt
Orden und Flaggen und besucht schon mit
14 Jahren einen Parteitag der
rechtsextremistischen NPD die Polizei
hat also schnell einen Täter und dessen
politischen Hintergrund ermittelt aber
wie genau lief die Tat ab
was wollte Köhler damit bewirken und war
er allein noch am Abend der Tat also am
Freitag bildet die bayerische Polizei
die Sonderkommission Theresienwiese mit
50 Beamten die sich an Spuren am Tatort
dokumentieren Lage und Zustand der
Leichen machen Fotos und befragen Zeugen
der wichtigste von ihnen an diesem Abend
Frank lauter jung er erkennt in den
grausam zerfetzten Überresten eines
toten genau den jungen Mann der kurz vor
der Explosion etwas in den Papierkorb
gelegt hat hilfreich ist auch das Köhler
seinen Perso dabei hat und sein
Studentenausweis mit Wohnsitz in
Donaueschingen die Kripo erfährt durch
das Informationssystem Nades deshalb
sehr schnell das Köhler ein
aktenkundiger Rechtsradikaler ist
er steht auf einer Liste von 200
Mitgliedern der Wehrsportgruppe Hoffmann
die Wehrsportgruppe Hoffmann wird 1973
vom Neonazi Karl-heinz Hoffmann
gegründet der gelernte Porzellan anmaler
und Grafiker radikalisierte sich schon
in den 50er Jahren in einer Nazi-Gruppe
namens Stahlhelm seine eigenen Gruppe
gehören in den 70ern bis zu 600
Mitglieder an im Januar 1980 wird sie
vom Bundesinnenminister Gerhard Baum von
der FDP verboten eine Weile betreiben
einzelne Mitglieder sie noch vom Libanon
aus weiter aber als Hoffmann 1981
verhaftet wird endet die Geschichte der
nazi-truppe
kurz gesagt die Polizei hat binnen
weniger Stunden einen Täter ermittelt
bei dem alles passt mit viel Aufwand
wird auch untersucht was genau für eine
Bombe das war die so viele Menschen
tötete anhand der überall gefundenen
Bomben später kommen die Experten zu
folgendem Ergebnis es handelt sich um
einen selbstgefertigten bombenkörper der
außen herum aus einer CO2
treibgasflasche von einem Feuerlöscher
besteht darin befand sich eine englische
Mörsergranate außerdem waren die
Hohlräume mit fast 1,4 Kilo reinem TNT
ausgefüllt alles in allem eine einfache
aber teuflische Konstruktion während die
Polizei ihre Arbeit macht stehen
Politiker in Bayern und in der
Hauptstadt Bonn derbe unter Stress in
München muss in kürzester Zeit
entschieden werden ob das Oktoberfest
weitergehen soll
viele in der Stadt erinnern sich an das
Olympia Attentat 8 Jahre zuvor damals
waren die Sommerspiele weitergegangen
obwohl bei dem palästinensischen Terror
gegen das Team aus Israel 11 Sportler
und ein Polizist gestorben waren über
diese Geschichte berichten wir euch in
der nächsten Folge von Tatort
Deutschland
auch diesmal trotz laufender
Ermittlungen lassen Münchens
Oberbürgermeister Erich Kiesel und
Polizeipräsident Manfred Schreiber des
fest weiterlaufen ihr Argument
Stadt und Bürger seien nicht von
Verbrechern erpressbar bis zum nächsten
Vormittag 11 Uhr werden hektisch alle
blutigen Spuren des Anschlags beseitigt
vier Tage nach dem Attentat gibt es
immerhin eine Gedenkveranstaltung und
das Fest wird einen Tag lang
unterbrochen eine Dreiviertelstunde
langwürdigen der Oberbürgermeister und
zwei Pfarrer die Toten parallel
beteiligen sich tausend Menschen an
einer Gegendemo sie halten ein
Transparent hoch mit der Aufschrift wir
trauern um die Opfer der faschistischen
Mörderbande
das Oktoberfest geht am 1 Oktober ganz
normal weiter es soll auch übrigens so
gut wie keine Umsatzverluste gegeben
haben
faschistische Mörderbande gab es etwa
noch Mittäter woher wollen die
Demonstranten das Wissen und warum
eigentlich soll ein Neonazi ausgerechnet
dass urdeutsche Oktoberfest angreifen
und dort wiederum wahllos zahlreiche
deutsche töten es gibt jetzt zusehends
eine politische Debatte um den Anschlag
denn Bayerns csu-ministerpräsident Franz
Josef Strauß hat das Verbot der
Wehrsportgruppe Hoffmann nicht gerade
unterstützt er sah in der Vereinigung
einen Haufen Spinner die man nicht so
wichtig nehmen sollte
und dieser Franz-Josef Strauß der will
jetzt Bundeskanzler werden nur neun Tage
nach dem fürchterlichen Anschlag am 5
Oktober will Bundeskanzler Helmut
Schmidt von der SPD wiedergewählt werden
und gegen ihn tritt nach einem brutalen
Machtkampf innerhalb der Union
Franz-Josef Strauß an der Wahlkampf ist
unversöhnlich auf beiden Seiten wird
kräftig polarisiert so ist in einem
wahlkampfsport der SPD zu hören wie
Strauß linke Demonstranten mit Nazis
gleichsetzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
keiner von uns keiner von uns
sollte jemals so reden wie er
Kameleon Werkzeuge Moskau Moskau
Fraktion und fähigkeitsgruppellosigkeit
Größen waren Heuchelei
Verantwortungslosigkeit
das wäre alles Originalton Strauß und
noch viel mehr dieser Mann hat keine
Kontrolle über sich und deshalb darf er
erst recht keine Kontrolle über unseren
Staat bekommen
weil von Deutschland Krieg ausgegangen
ist
deswegen gehört es
zur nationalen Pflicht der deutschen
den Frieden nicht nur zu wollen
sondern ihn auch tatsächlich
zu festigen und zu gestalten
CDU und CSU wiederum erwecken in ihrem
Spot den Eindruck als würde Schmidt
Westdeutschland in den Sozialismus
führen das ist Familie Strauß Mutter
eine Familie wie es noch Millionen
Familien in Deutschland gibt eine
Familie in der Vater Mutter Kinder den
gleichen Wunsch haben wie alle
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in unserem Lande
nämlich gewordenheit Sicherheit Friede
Franz Josef Strauß der deutsche
Politiker mit 30 Jahren Erfahrung bittet
am kommenden Sonntag um ihre Stimme
meine Lieben Mitbürgerinnen und
Mitbürger am kommenden Sonntag geht es
um eine ganz große politische
Entscheidung von geschichtlicher
Tragweite wie damals bei der ersten
Bundestagswahl 1949 damals ging es um
die Durchsetzung der soziale
Marktwirtschaft in einer freien
Gesellschaft gegen bürokratische
Landwirtschaft in einer sozialistischen
Gesellschaft damals ging es um den engen
Anschluss an den freien Westen gegen den
schrittweisen Einbau in der sowjetische
Machtsystem
heute geht es um die Erhaltung die
Stärkung den Ausbau unserer gemeinsamen
freiheitlichen demokratischen
Grundordnung gegen den volksfrauen
Terror auf den Straßen gegen
bürokratischen Sozialismus gegen den
spd-staat wollte Attentäter Gundolf
Köhler mit seiner Bombe die Wahl
beeinflussen sollte der Verdacht auf
linke fallen und damit der SPD geschadet
werden und die Frage ist natürlich auch
noch offen wer waren die Männer mit den
Gundolf Köhler vor und sogar während des
Anschlags gesehen wurde
wir machen weiter im zweiten Teil und
hoffen dass er natürlich da auch wieder
mit dabei seid eure Toni und euer Mirko